un prestigioso instituto transformado en
un hogar cientos de niños y adolescentes
haitianos se refugian en la institución
sant louis de gonzague para escapar de
la violencia de las bandas de cité
soleil uno de los municipios más pobres
y peligrosos de latinoamérica
solo este mes murieron más de 400
personas a manos de las pandillas en
este lugar
en cité soleil todo el mundo es víctima
niños recién nacidos mujeres embarazadas
varias personas han muerto yo soy una
víctima porque he perdido a una persona
cercana una amiga le dispararon cuando
iba a visitar a su padre que celebraba
su cumpleaños
los niños comenzaron a llegar a la
escuela hace una semana reciben
alimentos se divierten y duermen en las
aulas de este establecimiento llegar
hasta aquí fue todo una hazaña se
pusieron uniformes escolares
convenciendo a los líderes de las bandas
de que iban a la escuela logrando
escapar de la guerra territorial
y el lugar donde vivimos está controlado
por gpp una banda armada y la otra se
llama g9 por eso somos víctimas de la
violencia y hay muchas cosas que no
podemos decir para evitar la violencia
la onu ha llamado a impedir el
suministro de armas a las bandas
criminales de haití sin embargo
organizaciones como la red nacional de
defensa de los derechos humanos han
denunciado que el gobierno es parte del
conflicto y que promueve que la policía
haitiana se mantenga al margen de los
enfrentamientos